hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim all right I got my BP
Argonian oh just muscles shooting out
everywhere I got my nord great sword oh
just this wrong way Oh down here and I
got my ignore greats who are ready to
chop anything in half oh yeah these are
good carbs blue mushrooms I'm so so
manly
young jealous you're all jealous you
wish you to thought of an Argonian
warrior he just wish no but no you were
all like oh it's gotta be sneaky arconi
ins no no Warriors
what's my racial ability actually about
this disease
okay Argonian blood 50% resistant to
disease water breathing his skin
oh hell yeah recover health hell yeah I
need that that's perfect warrior thing
perfect for mighty mighty barbaric
barbarians hello by long yeah I wish
there were more variety to you know the
the slow-motion kill animations
or is there are there mods that increase
the number of animations because I'd
really like that
to some more cinematic stuff going on
Skellington chest hello all super
skilled watch this oh no oh right there
yeah
good thing I'm an art go nyan and I got
a bonus to lock-picking ever I'm gonna
I'm gonna be the best ever ever okay
oh and I've mentioned this before unlike
my livestream or some other channel well
I'm what I'm aiming to do with this
let's play is I'm gonna try to get
through the main storyline as fast as I
can
like I'm not gonna focus on any other
side quests I'm really just gonna do
like mostly on the main story quests
upswell Oh block I'm so bad at I didn't
block that one but I didn't need to
you're tough I yeah duh oh [ __ ] I didn't
oh [ __ ] block Oh Jeff where's my where's
my hist Caen and me though yeah favorite
piss skin okay I said use it
okay see this me ah dodge sprint away
missed dick ow didn't don't care his
skin
haha yes take that alright now that we
got that uh he didn't have anything for
a tough guy who got the chest up
apprentice of ass-kicking or an expert
or a master I don't know
- isn't that good oh alright getting
close I think and I know I know this
isn't technically a side quest because I
remember um that when I went in here I
didn't come in here looking for the
golden dragon claw I came in looking
here for the dragon thing something to
do with main quest so I know that if I
go in here and look gonna oh damn it
I got his skin still bring it on oh you
bring it on bring it on bring it on
bring it on
come here ah wrong Oh
ownage to the million Oh where'd you
come from doesn't matter I know where
you're going down those stairs all right
who else all my hiss can is gone you
yeah you're whoa fight like a man or
zombie these are technically zombies
there
patty so devil take that all right my
health does slowly recover how do you
increase your health regeneration I
don't know I need to get to like with it
an arrow I need to get to town cuz to
fight on expert I really need to like
invest in better armor you know an
enchants and all sorts of stuff like
that so like I'm no expert at it's game
by my own by no stretch of the
imagination
oh yeah I must have been here and here
for to get the gold clock because you
can't get through without the gold claw
that's right maybe I just got it
I don't know it's been like six months
since I last played this game I don't
remember anything just an idiot
apparently okay you put the golden claw
in or what key no miscellaneous is going
claw oh there it is bear moth owl and
you put it in never okay bear
that's wrong that's wrong wrong there we
go okay then you just get this
there goes okay all right yeah I must I
must see did I get the question that I
just get the clock cuz I don't remember
hitting that request
I don't know I hope rain is like going
in circles right now I have played this
game before I swear her I know what I'm
doing bats bats at all I did a big guy
up here a so-called tough guy
oh yeah Oh
words going right into my brain force
unrelenting force there we go no I'm
gonna give you a chance to get out oh
god you're tough oh you don't even have
a two-hander well oh yeah you dragon
shot block okay those delayed oh how I
was blocking ow but nope didn't matter
cuz you're down and I'm a badass you
chanted weapon that oh yeah here's the
dragon stone that's what I was looking
for got those stars on it wait a minute
is that where is that where all the
locations of all the things are really I
didn't know that it told me that Trista
all right
strength frenzy potion soul gem petty
soldier okay was there anything else in
this cave that I might have missed
probably oh oh
orcas battle-ax I like it I like it get
rid of the ancient battle ax why do I
need that ancient nord axe orcish battle
axe oh hell yeah I don't know I don't
remember where orcish weapons land on
the spectrum of good stuff miss but I
know it's pretty good and plus it's a
battle ax come on chop things in half
all right going out and then after this
I turn in the quest and go straight to
that village in the middle of the map
the middle village where that yarrow guy
is I don't know
flowers skull yes I'll take the skull to
some sort of grave that people respected
chest I already looked at HS what am i
doing see that's how bad my memory and I
don't even remember that I looked in
that chest five seconds ago
well hello thank you pretty too bad
you're all gonna die if you didn't
attack me you wouldn't die but just
waited wait I just jump off and on some
exit this is who look mammoth bones
particular reason for the mammoth bones
where they just for show
alright whatever okay now I'm headed to
the marker or to turn in the quest which
I I'm assuming that it close to the
marker Wow good that that pretty that is
beautiful I love love love how much love
and care I love I love I love to love
love I love love and love to love love
no I really do appreciate how much care
they put into the world and just the
environment that's part of what makes
this game so great it's just it's a real
world that you can explore and it's
lagging again because for some reason my
game likes to not perform at maximum not
fire over there I do not need to harvest
firewood I why am I not sprinting
there's something over there
hello we got over here when our godean
so I can swim leg about hello
you you you an enemy you friendly you
friendly I've been hunting and fishing
in these parts for years that's nice but
are you friendly coaching Oh take a look
okay you guys store going on here
can I sell you something for sure you
know how much gold but I'll sell ya that
and that
wait what am i doing wait what is it
going what what
it's just disappearing it's not selling
it's just I'm giving it no you're
stealing you're stealing from me
you [ __ ] it's ok you probably needed it
anyway Oh swimming through the water cuz
I'm a water breathing Argonian yeah it's
kind of weird that they have water well
catch salmon got the salmon yeah
in my mouth I caught it in my mouth wait
whatever stop judging me it is weird
that argonians could breathe underwater
because it doesn't look like they have
gills of any sort whatever I sprint
through the water iceprince wimp
no cannot sprint I'm glad I helped I'm
at it in the right direction
oh here's a road okay we're good we're
good
Grady's drinking speed I need a horse as
I can't sprint forever I neither can
horses breath whatever Oh
stamina takes so long to regen Oh wolf
take some battle action walk yeah
that's what I thought yeah I'm a badass
alright and I just lost my stamina again
to some wolves probably didn't even
deserve a power attack okay I wonder if
heavy armor makes me slower too probably
does I'm kind of wobbling ah let me put
my my no I like the third person there
we go
put it away do I keep doing oh yeah like
a beefy I am you can see my arms let's
bigger than my head and I need to sleep
the end cuz is closed probably closed at
night right maybe not maybe I just turn
in the quest at any time
oh wow ha I'm sorry I'm sorry I
apologize I apologize faint I'll think
it was unlocked away from me she's
already mine okay that's nice whatever
man don't need to tell your problems to
every passing stranger some of us you
know have our own problems
all right where's the inky hello give me
a groom's and food drink - no I cook
you're nothing not you are hello visit
yes Inge it's yours for a day thank you
which one is going bad we need to get a
new batch yeah this one did you hear me
oh come on Hales going bad Al's going
again oh yeah potatoes in your ears
after all in ears make sure we get a
fresh batches which bed is ma here we go
sleep until mourn about 6 hours
oh it's Jay Bob beauty sleep like I've
said before I love games adieu
Oh alchemy lab oh um to test out the
ingredients I need to eat them because
that seems totally safe yum yum yum yum
yum yum yum dum dum dum dum
mmm tasty oh that's probably not good
are anyway so now I can try to create
health potions store health I have none
all right let me just experiment I guess
weird if I help that's not bad
just fire our failure yeah
story of my life this fire was frost
damage health why would I want it Dan oh
is that for a poison or something on ah
that's more like oh yeah alchemy
increase I'm the innkeeper Mike failure
I'll guess right I have anything in
restore health nope but I found
everything about Blue Mountain flower
all right whatever I don't have enough
ingredients to really get into this so
we don't get a lot of I slept let me go
turn in the quest hmm ah such a
beautiful day and Skyrim really is
gorgeous out oh that I about to explode
possibly I wouldn't doubt it eat all
those random ingredient okay actually
this is gonna have to wait until next
time I'm all out of time for this
episode thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye bye